I wonder if this is a smaller side we
could say just uh I haven't gotten to
know Elon very well because the the
silliness
the willingness to engage in the
absurdity of it all
and have fun
what is that what is that uh is that
just a quirk of Personality or is that a
fundamental aspect of a human who's
running six plus companies well that's a
relief valve just like video games and
politopia and Elden ring or release
valves for him
um and he does have an explosive sense
of humor as you know and the weird thing
is when he makes the abrupt transition
from dark demon mode and you're in the
conference room and he has really become
upset about something and not only their
dog Vibes but there's dark words
emanating and he's saying your
resignation will be accepted if you die
you know Etc
and then something pops and he pulls out
his phone and pulls up a Bonnie Python's
get you know like the School of silly
walks or whichever John Cleese it would
and then he starts laughing again and
things break so it's
it's almost as if he has different modes
the emulation of human mode the
engineering mode the dark and Demon mode
and certainly there is the silly and
getting mode
yeah you've actually opened the Elon
book with the quotes from Elon and from
Steve Jobs so elon's quote is to anyone
of offended I just want to say this is
an SNL I just want to say I reinvented
electric cars and I'm sending people to
Mars on a rocket ship did you also think
I was going to be a chill normal dude
and then the quote from Steve Jobs of
course is the people who are crazy
enough to think they can change the
world are the ones who do so um
what do you think is the role of the old
uh Madness and genius what do you think
they're all of crazy in this well first
of all let's both stipulate that musk is
crazy at times I mean and
then let's figure out and I try to do it
through storytelling not through
highfalutin preaching
uh where that craziness works you know
give me a story tell me another go tell
me where he's crazy
and
you know the almost final example uh AI
but him shooting off Starship for the
first time
uh and between an aborted countdown and
the shoot off he goes to Miami to an ad
sales conference and meets Linda
yaccarino for the first time make sure
the CEO I mean there's a very
impulsiveness to him then he flies back
they launch Starship
and
you realize that there's a drive and
there are demons and there's also
craziness
and
you sometimes want to pull those out you
want to take away his phone so he
doesn't tweet at 3am you want to say
quit being so crazy
but then you realize there's a wonderful
line of Shakespeare and measure from
measure at the very end he says even the
best are molded out of faults and so you
take the faults of musk for example
which includes a craziness that can be
endearing but also craziness that's just
like effing crazy
uh as well as
this drive and Demon mode
I don't know that you can take that
strand out of the fabric and the fabric
remains whole
I wonder
sometimes it saddens me that we live in
a society that doesn't celebrate even
the darker aspects of crazy in
acknowledging that it all as comes in
one package it's the man in the arena
versus the critic and the Man in the
rain versus the regulator and to make it
more prosaic